hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to killing room the game
show or you can find your dreams and
make money and also probably die a lot
but I'm good at not dying as far as I
know in my life but I'm gonna be good to
go what the hell is that oh that's cool
oh so you if you stream this game I can
create a custom URL ah that's awesome
why me doesn't work now but if I were to
stream this game I could create this
custom URL and then you guys could dick
me over which I know you do and I don't
blame you for that it make it more
interesting I'm too good at this I need
a little I need a little spice in my
life for my tea ass guardian reporting
for duty I do like being a nice ass
guardian so I'm gonna get into this oh I
was something completely different
apparently oh this is like a roguelike
game where if you don't know what a
roguelike game I'm talking about before
it's where you only get one chance if
you die you die everything's randomly
generated and stuff like that okay so I
just have to do good and not die is that
what I'm supposed to be hey how you
doing hello whoa that's a bit handsy
with that that's that's a little a
little aggressive
hey hey stop that David think about it
okay sorry excuse my blood hand you know
I don't have a lot of time to wash it's
just the burning flesh of the previous
contestants from the second floor please
go to the elevator which will take you
to the training floor show me if you
survived okay you were looking off to my
left I wasn't sure if you were talking
to me or somebody else here but I guess
I'm the only one stupid enough to go on
this game show you know you you jiggle a
lot which is something I appreciate
let's see how popular I can get what if
this is how YouTube was like you had to
go and into her killing death pit just
to get subscribers and your popularity
it was based on the fact that you're not
dead yet and you got a wall plus you
tubers oh god that's morbid but somehow
I want that and then you guys would
either help me or hinder
it'd be the Hunger Games literally
that's the only thing you get if you
want to be pop okay you must use a
lockpick to get them open okay well why
also what's with my hands they really
were blood covered hands and I have no
idea why
let me just hang on here I don't know
why this is important habit okay I'll
get him eventually don't worry yeah this
is definitely how lockpicks work all
right I did it oh god what is that a
floating baby head
Razia bastard way to deal with enemies
take the barrel and move it next to the
new one and then BOOM dangerous don't
worry
oh god why am i killing these baby oh
why are the babies big Dyne floating
heads a lot of things are Oh
oh that's nice I'm not getting very
popular though I really want to figure
out how to do my popularity better than
do boxes and make a way up for yourself
grab those boob boxes
so you don't mind my blood hands
therefore every bloody and extra grungy
pokey yeah that worked okay physics is
awfully forgiving in this environment
hey I'm a winner dick I am losing
popularity and quick items and fridges
ridiculous
nothing good ever comes from the fridges
only monsters and what is worse food
wait a minute I am getting a lot of
mixed signals here boob lady so mean and
not open the fridges but you're okay I
don't know what you mean I have no idea
what you're talking about
oh I like this cube I like it already
it's got sass and if there's one thing
that markiplier likes its sass I don't
know if I needed training oh I'm pretty
good hey hope with me I don't have a
home apparently a living I live in my
rags in my blood I just got a blood
house you know it's nothing bad
not too shabby assembled it from all the
blood of the people I killed
you know pretty impressive right did I
mention I killed a lot of people yeah
it's true I'm great like that anyway
who's here hello
how do you d hmm alright little old but
I'll take it
okay
this feels wrong for some reason like
how is that tactically advantageous take
bad item get popularity did I do that
I mean alright I'll do it you item good
leg bad leg no leg you're still gonna
die er you lost one leg that's not an
item it's not an item you just cut off
my leg what head why'd you do that
[ __ ] you what
oh god this homily oh god my brain is
gonna melt hello [ __ ] okay right hey I
got money what the [ __ ] is this thing
what is this Oh what is that oh I don't
know what that did oh this is where I
lost my leg for popularity why did I do
that
popularity yeah whoa wait hey I'm out of
bullets okay we got another bad item can
I get my leg back please pretty please
say I'm a dick for exhalation I'm a dick
I'm a dick baby I'm a big ol dick but
apparently I have max health somehow I
have no idea how oh god I love this kid
oh what's going on wait I got a bit
alright gotten tripple kill baby is that
a fight can I keep my leg back please
get Goliath crush your enemies with a
single strike look at me look at me and
my French oh that's a lot of you are you
dead yet no oh yes please
force lives for pistols only yeah I'll
take this whoa that's up
that's a funky looking weapon am I not
right about that money shut up yes money
baby
I want money I want all didn't Monday
all righty then
oh god my Hobley [ __ ] ass needs to get
a move on what the [ __ ] did I take that
I didn't care about popularity
boström get my leg back
[Music]
oh my god are those actual statistics
all right ah man very low there Oh
oh jeez ow I can't jump I have one leg
oh [ __ ] oh god I can't sprint [ __ ] you
dude you suck balls my [ __ ] one leg
please can I have my leg back I got a
boss I dead but keen desires some
supernatural qualities you get a
crosshair I not have a cross before I
totally didn't even realize that hey I'm
a big dick God what'd he do I still have
no lag did I get a goddamn lag sorry you
didn't have tan you didn't obtain enough
votes in this level you need at least 10
votes and you have zero
I don't yeah I don't have anyone doing
this with me right now I just don't
I can tweet this out though I wonder if
that would work would that work
yeah I got a I got a fiddle with this
hey hey hey gang need a favor
um I'm playing a cool new game that has
this feature where you guys can
influence me as I play I have no idea
how this works but if you guys click
this link you can do stuff as I play
alarm you'll see the results in a future
video and possibly we'll do it live
at a later date love you love you long
time
mark it's entirely possible to do
something but honestly who knows okay
all right
populate hall she's so much
customization I don't know can I get
speed I only have one leg can people
vote to get me another goddamn leg how
about more crit chance I like crit
chance can I get more armor please all
right continue I'm going for it baby
because apparently I don't know people
are gonna watch now I've got good idea
dammit Mahabali bitch-ass who's here
hello Oh seasons what are you yeah takes
a long time to reload I'm I'm gonna owe
you guys explode well I am [ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] hey it's
our fridge gonna hobble over there
Jesus dabba doo boo a bit D bit die [ __ ]
okay
oh dude alrighty then
well Habba Habba Habba Habba Habba Habba
[ __ ] [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off [ __ ] you're scary
you're scary oh Jesus oh hey I got
bloody grimy hands and only one leg how
you doing hey wow yeah
oh the door god damn it Oh who's gonna
go well
I don't wanna [ __ ] a living snowman and
it doesn't so what you said oh jeez
that's not a good sign at spoink ah
that's not good mom out of animal
apparently
Jesus okay
well kill that guy apparently that
didn't go well but no gay give my god
damn wedding back yeah chewed map you
have a chance to reveal parts of the map
and each floor
great can I shout I'm a dick into this
not enough popularity the popularity god
damn it I'm not popular enough oh man I
[Music]
mean not really I guess it's appropriate
but it's like blindly APRA you guys
don't know what I'm doing why did you
give me he okay alright thanks thanks
for not giving me bleeding that's nice
while sprinting you sometimes tripping
lose all use I can't I got one there
just one leg you [ __ ] man ah [ __ ]
so I'm just one foot with a heel on it
hobbling even worse than I was before
got it got up like speed alright you
know that's [ __ ] it I'm good I'm still
going have it a heavy I'm spreading my
heel my one heel oh it's so like us so
sickening I guess it's hard to look at
Oh what are you oh geez oh god damn it
oh god this is really where my my speeds
being hindered get anybody I'm glad I
did that you trying to do [ __ ] how about
that guy oh jeez
oh good I can get in another bad yep
what did I get you're trying to talk
things with enemies but it's a terrible
damage yeah I guess it's not as bad as
losing my goddamn fight why are you boo
yeah what are these things
what are these Waterloo's oh jeez oh
[ __ ] me oh god damn it all these things
suck my balls oh if I die then at least
it would be merciful on me because I
don't have a [ __ ] fight
ah god damn it oh [ __ ] I got those fun
though God if I wasn't getting sick the
whole time from the camera jostling me
hobbly markiplier gotta do I'm gonna win
missed my day
[ __ ] dude that was awesome I love that I
want to do that again I'm gonna do that
again I'm gonna put out a new link I'm
gonna tell everybody that they killed me
and then I'm going to do this again
because goddamn that game was fun I mean
I can't do it live right now but good
god that's awesome and it's like so
funny because they have no idea what
they're doing
I'm just gonna tweet out they killed me
oh man that's so fun so anyway I'm gonna
play more of this and we're gonna get
more from you guys and then we're gonna
figure out something to do it live
because this is really fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]